[موسيقى]
افتتحنا مكتبنا في ابوظبي منذ فتره قصيره
كجزء من استراتيجيتنا وفهمنا للاتفاق
الابراهيمي هو ليس مجرد شعار بل سيتحقق
بالفعل هذه خطوه كبيره من وجهه نظرنا
لتاسيس وجود المستمر هنا في ابوظبي وعلى
امل ان تكون هذه هي الخطوه الاولى لفتح
المزيد من المكاتب حول المنطقه اعتقد ان
هذه الخطوه منطقيه ضمن شراكتنا
الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
نستعرض هنا بعض منتجاتنا بعد ان حصلنا على
الموافقه لعرض جميع انظمتنا هنا خلال
عمليه تعتمد على العمل الذي نقوم به الا
ان هدفنا الختامي هو جزء من الاستراتيجيه
القوميه وسياسه وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه
وهي جلب احدث انظمه رافائيل واكثرها تقدما
الى جانب منتجات اخرى من الصناعه الدفاعيه
الاسرائيليه الى شركائنا في جميع انحاء
العالم خاصه في هذه المنطقه كجزء من
استراتيجيه توسيع الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]